[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen sie ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend und was sportlich an steht
heute mit norbert lehmann spender
informieren und das sind unsere themen
an diesem freitag
extra steuer auf krisengewinner bremen
macht druck im bundesrat und will etwa
mineralölkonzerne stärker zur kasse
bitten
personalmangel bei airlines und
flughäfen in der hauptreisezeit drohen
lange warteschlangen hunderte flüge
fallen aus
und trump schwer belastet der
ex-us-präsident sei für den sturm auf
das kapitol verantwortlich sagt jetzt
ein untersuchungsausschuss
[Musik]
trotz des tank rabatt bleiben
spritpreise auf rekordniveau
darum streitet die bundesregierung über
eine sogenannte über gewinn steuer für
mineralölkonzerne und andere
krisengewinner spd und grüne sind dafür
die fdp dagegen auf initiative bremens
ist das thema jetzt auch im bundesrat
angekommen und schauen wir mal worum es
da jetzt konkret geht die über gewinn
steuer ist eine art sondersteuer sie
belastet den teil des gewinnes der über
den normal gewinn hinausgeht im
vergleich zu vorkrisenjahren beispiel
mineralölkonzerne diese vier großen
haben im ersten quartal ihren gewinn im
vergleich zum vorjahr verdoppelt von
etwa 15 auf rund 34 milliarden us-dollar
über die diskussion bei uns katharina
weisgerber
tanken ist teuer geblieben der tank
rabatt verpufft die preise steigen fast
so schnell wie sie vor zehn tagen gerade
erst gefallen sind ich bin jede woche
tanken und jedes mal sind es über 100
euro und macht keinen spaß macht einfach
kein spaß also hat man sich ein bisschen
mehr mühe geben können dass das nicht so
bei den konzernen landet sondern auch
wirklich beim bürger
weil vor allem die mineralölkonzerne
durch den krieg in der ukraine riesige
gewinne machen sollen solche kriegs und
krisengebieten extra besteuert werden um
damit die milliardenschweren
entlastungspaket mitzufinanzieren
den antrag hat bremen heute in den
bundesrat eingebracht der rohölpreis ist
zwar ein bisschen gestiegen aber nicht
so sehr und jedenfalls nicht im
verhältnis der spritpreise stattdessen
haben sich die ölmultis die eigenen
taschen gefüllt mit der steigenden
differenz zwischen spritpreis und
rohölpreis zum vorschlag zustimmung aber
auch deutliche kritik im bundesrat der
eindruck wäre verheerend dass die
regierung aufgrund kurzfristiger
politischer erwägungen willkürlich
festlegt welche diese gewinne nun in
ordnung sind und welche nicht das könnte
tische anschein erwecken die regierung
haben mit den grundlegenden prinzipien
der marktwirtschaft gebrochen viele
details sind noch unklar etwa wir
ankommen an die profite der
mineralölkonzerne den großen reibach
machen die internationalen
energiekonzerne machen die ölscheichs
und das jetzt abzuschöpfen für uns als
deutschland ist gar nicht so einfach der
vorschlag aus bremen hat es auf die
tagesordnung im politischen berlin
geschafft dort könnte er noch für streit
in der ampelkoalition sorgen
schon beschlossen hat der bundesrat das
sogenannte sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
geplant sind etwa der kauf neuer
kampfjets schiffe und panzer außerdem
wird der mindestlohn von oktober an auf
12 euro je stunde angehoben und die
rechte von bürgerinnen und bürger auf
mindeststandards beim internetzugang
werden gestärkt
die urlaubs sehnsucht nach zwei corona
jahren ist riesengroß mit dem flugzeug
richtung sonne die reisebranche erwartet
einen hervorragenden sommer und
tatsächlich der run auf tickets ist
enorm aber es gibt probleme der grund in
der pandemie wurde massenhaft personal
abgebaut derzeit fehlen bundesweit etwa
5.500 leute schätzt die branche etwa
beim check-in für das verladen der
koffer oder auch bei den flugbegleitern
allein die lufthansa muss für juli rund
900 flüge streichen nicola albrecht
große verärgerung bei hunderten
passagieren heute früh am flughafen
berlin brandenburg
22 flüge kurzfristig gestrichen der
grund das bordpersonal der linie easyjet
streikt für bessere arbeitsbedingungen
ein kleiner warnstreik aber ein zeichen
für das aktuell größte problem der
luftfahrtbranche nach zwei jahren
pandemie sind 5500 beschäftigte nicht
mehr da einerseits haben
fluggesellschaften in der zeit auch
personal abgebaut das rächt sich nun
weil der luftverkehr sehr stark zurück
kommt die nachfrage sehr hoch ist auf
der anderen seite hat natürlich die
lange zeit der kurzarbeit auch dazu
geführt dass beschäftigte beim
kabinenpersonal sich andere tätigkeiten
gesucht haben so auch julia sarah 13
jahre lang hat sie als flugbegleiterin
bei der lufthansa gearbeitet dann kam
die kurzarbeit so schlecht organisiert
erklärt sie dass sie sich gezwungen sie
zu kündigen wir hatten in der kurzarbeit
hatten wir kollegen die wirklich
unfassbar viel geflogen sind und wir
hatten kollegen die wie ich zum beispiel
ein halbes jahr gar nicht geflogen sind
die sich das gewünscht hätten die
lufthansa habe ihr und anderen die
kündigung sogar nahegelegt fügt sie
hinzu und nun fehlt auch am boden und
bei der sicherheit lange schlangen
verpasste flüge schon jetzt alltag für
juli haben die fluggesellschaften wegen
des personalmangels bereits vorsorglich
mehr als tausend flüge gestrichen
flughafenbetreiber schauen mit sorge auf
die sommerferien es ist in der tat so
dass die gesamte luftverkehrsbranche vor
allem in europa probleme hat das
betrifft alle flug großen flughäfen das
bedeutet dass wir auch im terminal
selber schauen wo muss noch etwas getan
werden damit es einfacher läuft für
passagiere deren flug nicht gestrichen
wird heißt das wohl möglichst früh am
flughafen seien
zwei tage fünf länder bundeskanzler
stolzes auf dem westlichen balkan
unterwegs um dort gleich mehreren
ländern wieder hoffnung auf die eu zu
machen erstes ziel kosovo nach dem
gespräch mit scholz kündigte
regierungschef putin an noch in diesem
jahr einen beitrittsantrag zu stellen
scholz hat das kosovo und serbien dazu
aufgefordert ein abkommen zur
gegenseitigen anerkennung zu schließen
darauf drängt er auch in belgrad beim
serbischen präsidenten vucic der darauf
empört reagierte außerdem legte scholz
dem land einen kurswechsel seiner
russlandfreundlichen politik nahe
nicht alle verbrechen und gräueltaten
des ukraine krieges werden bekannt
einige aber schon laut
menschenrechtsorganisation human rights
watch soll russlands militär in cerny f
im märz dutzende zivilisten getötet und
auch verbotene streumunition eingesetzt
haben aber auch der ukraine werden
vorwürfe gemacht für uns vor ort
ingenieur julia held hier ist ihr
bericht
eine ruine das ist alles was viktor
schöne stadt geblieben ist 33 jahre hat
er gelebt jetzt ist nichts mehr wie es
waren sieben bomben glaube ich eine dort
drüben neben dem haus zum beispiel und
eine direkt neben der apotheke
und diese bomben waren nicht die
einzigen fast fünf wochen lang stand er
unter russischen beschuss raketen und
bomben haben wohnhäuser supermärkte und
sogar krankenhäuser in schutt und asche
gelegt wie klaffende wunden liegen sie
mitten im herzen der stadt
eltville hat einige dieser angriffe
untersucht seien als zivile ziele
gewesen so die jungen rights watch
expertin und damit mutmaßliche
kriegsverbrechen wir halten die angriffe
für rechtswidrig wir haben in keinem
dieser fälle ein militärisches ziel in
der nähe gefunden dass diese angriffe
rechtfertigen würde und doch gibt es
auch kritik am ukrainischen militär
immer wieder würde es schulen nutzen um
dort die eigenen truppen zu stationieren
so human rights watch schulen die oft
mitten in wohngebieten liegen auch
ingenieur hatte das fatale folgen
mindestens drei menschen kamen alleine
hier ums leben
dem haus von viktor schätzle stand aber
gab es kein militär auch nicht in der
nähe gerisch dann ist sicher den
russischen angreifern seien die menschen
hier einfach egal gewesen
in der ukraine sind derzeit
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister erste mir
und gesundheitsminister lauterbach
lauterbach besuchte in lemberg mehrere
krankenhäuser und sagte der ukraine
medizinische hilfe bei der versorgung
von kriegsopfern zu
erstem er beriet in kiew mit den
ukrainischen landwirtschaftsminister wie
das land getreide exportieren kann
obwohl russland die häfen am schwarzen
meer blockiert und ober wollen wir jetzt
sprechen johannes hano ist in der nähe
von nikolajew johannes die ganze welt
wartet auf ukrainisches getreide wie
steht es um mögliche ausbauen was
bekommst du mit
also zur ausfuhr zur aufhebung der
seeblockade und der ausführung über
frachtschiffe ist gibt keine alternative
dass es überhaupt nicht vorstellbar 25
millionen tonnen getreide lagern in den
häfen jetzt kommen noch mal mindestens
50 millionen tonnen in den nächsten zwei
wochen durch die neue ernte hinzu die
ukraine hat versucht mit güterzügen
richtung rumänien anteil zumindest
abzutransportieren daraufhin hat
russland die einzige eisenbahnbrücke
bombardiert dann ist man auf die straße
ausgewichen richtung rumänien das mal
angeschaut da waren mehr als 8000 lkw
und jeden tag werden es mehr an der
grenze die gar nicht entladen werden
können weil die häfen dort viel zu klein
sind und selbst wenn man andere
güterstrecken nutzen würde dann müsste
man davon ausgehen dass russland auch
diese strecken bombardiert und wenn man
komplett auf lkw ausweichen müsste dann
bräuchte man ungefähr zwei millionen lkw
dass wir eine schlange von knapp 30.000
kilometern also auch völlig illusorisch
zur aufhebung der seeblockade gibt es
keine alternative live aus der ukraine
war dass johannes hano vielen dank
online in der zdf- heute haben wir
weitere details zu den zeitgleichen
solidaritätsbesuch in der minister erste
mir und lauterbach sowie über
deutschlands hilfen für die kriegsopfer
jetzt in die usa wenn es noch eines
beweises bedurfte wie sehr dort
gesellschaft und demokratie ins wanken
geraten sind dann wurde er am 6 januar
2021 geliefert ein wütender mob von
trump anhängern stürmte das us capitol
bilanz zehn tote über 140 zum teil
schwerverletzte die schuldfrage dieser
historischen ungeheuerlichkeit hat ein
untersuchungsausschuss versucht
aufzuarbeiten
über die ergebnisse benjamin daniel aus
washington
diese bisher unveröffentlichten videos
zeigen einmal mehr dass viele von
schramms anhängern die vor knapp
anderthalb jahren das us capitols
stürmten zu allem bereit waren was immer
nötig ist wir sind bereit für diese
sache zu sterben
polizistin carolina trotz wurde beim
versuch das kapitol zu verteidigen so
schwer verletzt dass sie bis heute nicht
wieder arbeiten kann
was ich gesehen habe waren krieg sehen
so etwas kannte ich bisher nur aus
filmen die gesichter meiner kollegen
waren blutverschmiert ich bin in denen
blutlachen am boden ausgerutscht
der ausschuss veröffentlichte unter
anderem die aussage des damaligen
justizministers
er hatte trump gesagt dass er die
theorie einer gestohlenen wahl für zitat
schwachsinn halte und selbst trump
tochter sieht das so
ich respektiere justizminister bahn also
akzeptierte ich was er sagt
für donald trump die verlorene wahl erst
der beginn einer sich ausbreitenden
vielschichtigen verschwörungstheorie mit
dem ziel sich über die
präsidentschaftswahlen zu stellen und
damit die stimmen von millionen
amerikanern einfach wegzuschmeißen und
dennoch wollen die meisten republikaner
das alles nicht wahr haben die
demokraten setzen deshalb alles daran
die ermittlungen möglichst schnell
voranzutreiben denn sollten sie bei den
zwischenwahlen im november die mehrheit
im repräsentantenhaus verlieren dann
würde das mit sicherheit auch das ende
des untersuchungsausschusses bedeuten
trumps putschversuch ist zwar am 6
januar 2021 gescheitert seine angriffe
auf die demokratie ist damit aber noch
lange nicht vorbei
frankreich steht vor einer spannenden
politischen entscheidung kurz nach
seiner wiederwahl muss präsident mag
jetzt um seine absolute mehrheit im
parlament bangen nach letzten umfragen
könnte ihnen bei der abstimmung zur
nationalversammlung am sonntag ein
linkes bündnis sogar auf den zweiten
platz verdrängen aus paris angereist
guten tag ich bin kandidat an des
sechzehnten bezirks am sonntag ist die
erste runde die linke-kandidatin chili
muri auf stimmenfang bei der pariser
bourgeoisie in einem nobelviertel in dem
traditionell marken gewählt wird erst
einfach besser bei der wirtschaft es
gibt weniger arbeitslosigkeit und klar
muss man den armen helfen aber doch
nicht um diesen preis
von solchen aussagen lässt sich die
linke nicht unterkriegen
die menschen wollen magna und seine
klassen politik nicht mehr sie ist
überzeugt von dem neuen bündnis aus
linken kommunisten grünen und
sozialisten die dafür sorgen wollen dass
der mindestlohn angehoben wird die rente
mit 60 kommt angeführt wird das neue
bündnis zum ehemaligen
präsidentschaftskandidaten jean-luc
mischung der ist zuversichtlich
makros mehrheit wollte dass alle vor der
wahl im tiefschlaf sind bloß über nicht
reden und niemanden aufregen sie können
machen was sie wollen aber wir machen
das anders und nun legen wir vorne und
sie kriegen panik
sollten die pest die mehrheit bekommen
hofft man schon neuer premierminister zu
werden doch man hat wenig sympathien für
den herausforderer
das ist eine partei die wollen einfach
nur verbieten und eine reichensteuer
dass es nicht gut für unser land
wer bekommt die mehrheit in umfragen
liegen ließ und die partei von matten
fast gleichauf
ich wähle makro nein nein nein das
machst du nicht ich verbiete es dir -
oder niemand
kaum masken wenig abstände corona spielt
für viele gerade keine große rolle mehr
allerdings warnt das rk ii wegen der
neuen omikron subtypen dass die
infektionen schon im sommer deutlich
zunehmen könnten und so sieht es aktuell
aus innerhalb von 24 stunden wurden 77
1878 neue corona fälle registriert das
sind 35.000 185 mehr als vor einer woche
106 todesfälle kamen hinzu und die
inzidenz liegt nun bei 3
118,7
gegen eine andere viruskrankheit hat die
ständige impfkommission jetzt für
risikogruppen eine impfung empfohlen es
geht um die affen pocken bislang sind in
deutschland mehr als 130 infektionsfälle
mit dem affen pockenvirus registriert
worden die details haben fabian köhler
und christina i welt seit jahren schon
beschäftigt sich professor reinhold
förster von der medizinischen hochschule
hannover mit pocken impfstoffen affen
trocken so der immunologe nichts neues
neu dagegen die aktuelle übertragungs
weise die infektion ist immer vom tier
zum menschen gegangen und von der
türmchen zu menschen von affen zu
menschen was jetzt neu ist ist die
situation dass sie von menschen zum
menschen übertragbar sind seit mai mehr
als 130 fälle in deutschland meist
harmlos wie verlauf grundsätzlich können
männer wie frauen erkranken betroffenen
jetzt vor allem homosexuelle männer die
an szene partys teilgenommen hatten das
hat nichts mit stigmatisierung einer
sexuellen präferenz zu tun sondern
einfach nur mit einem bestimmten
risikoverhalten hafen pocken wird im
gegensatz zu kohle es vor allen dingen
übertragen durch engen körperlichen
kontakt direkten kontakt und zwar mit
verletzter haut oder mit schleimhäuten
die stiko empfiehlt daher eine für
kontaktpersonen von erkrankten sowie für
männer mit häufig wechselnden
gleichgeschlechtlichen sexualpartnern
und zwar mit dem normalen poppen
impfstoff schützt auch vor affen pocken
sogar noch nach einer infektion die
ansteckungsgefahr anders als beim corona
virus gering dass die affen pocken
mutieren so experten eher
unwahrscheinlich das ist kein rna virus
dessen doppelsträngige dna virus dies
sind extrem stabil die aktuellen fälle
so der mediziner daher kein grund zur
panik aber zur wachsamkeit
an der hochschule in hamm lippstadt in
westfalen hat ein 34-jähriger vier
menschen mit einem messer verletzt
einige von ihnen schwer nach ersten
erkenntnissen der polizei hat der täter
auf den fluren der hochschule menschen
mit einem messer angegriffen auf dem weg
zum hörsaal sei er dann von studenten
überwältigt worden die hintergründe der
tat sind unklar
wir sind jetzt beim fußball und bei
norbert und es geht für die deutsche
fußball nationalmannschaft morgen gegen
ungarn die dritte begegnung in der
nations league bundestrainer hansi flick
will unbedingt einen sieg in budapest
einfahren auch um das dfb team für den
einsatz und aufwand zu belohnen nach den
beiden unentschieden gegen italien und
england
sabri konnte wegen beschwerden in der
wade nur leicht trainieren noch offen ob
er morgen auflaufen kann auf das flic
team wartet in ungarn eine
anspruchsvolle aufgabe nach england ist
das schwerste spiel das man haben kann
gegen england zu spielen der mannschaft
die sehr kompakt sehr gut geordnet
defensiv agiert die kommas zuletzt
angesichts der hohen belastung mit vier
länderspielen in elf tagen fordert
fliegt ein umdenken bei den verbänden um
den profis mehr erholung zu gönnen vier
spiele sind einfach zu viel nach so
einer langen saison man sollte schon mal
irgendwann ja einfach mal hinterfragen
wie kann man die spiele dann
letztendlich auch oder wie kann man
ihnen auch mal eine pause gönnen er
kritisiert den vollen terminplan
andererseits braucht sein team
wettkämpfe um sich für die wm
einzuspielen
zweitliga-absteiger dynamo dresden hat
markus anfang als neuen cheftrainer
verpflichtet
der 47 jährige erhält einen
zweijahresvertrag bei den sachsen im
november war anfang als coach bei werder
bremen zurückgetreten nachdem bekannt
wurde dass er einen gefälschten
impfausweis benutzt hatte der dfb
verhängte eine sperre gegen anfang die
ab dem heutigen tag zur bewährung
ausgesetzt ist
oskar otto hat kampflos die nächste
runde beim tennis-turnier in stuttgart
erreicht sein viertelfinal kontrahent
der hatte wegen bauchschmerzen absagen
müssen der kölner trifft morgen im
halbfinale auf den hamilton
vorjahresfinalisten matteo betty
zur formel 1 und zum großen preis von
aserbaidschan da ist ferrari-pilot
charlie klar im freien training die
schnellste zeit gefahr der monegasse
verwies sergio perez im red bull auf den
zweiten platz sein teamgefährte und
weltmeister max daten wurde dritter
sebastian vierteln im aston martin
musste sich dagegen mit platz elf
begnügen mit schumacher wurde vorletzter
das war's von ford dann sagen vielen
dank wir haben noch schöne aussichten
das wetter beschert uns ein sommerliches
wochenende weitere details gleich mit
christa oben marietta slomka und das
heute journal um 22 uhr sofern möglich
haben sie einen entspannten start ins
wochenende wir sagen danke fürs
zuschauen und ist
[Musik]
guten abend das azorenhoch schickt uns
einen teil der unser wochenende
sommerlich werden lässt sein
gegenspieler das islandtief wir sehen
dass hier auf dem satelliten film von
heute als prächtigen wolken kringel kann
es aber nicht lassen so ein bisschen
mitzumischen und schickt uns an seiner
front ein paar harmlose wolken die
liegen heute nacht vor allem im norden
und im nordwesten fällt vereinzelt mal
ras was raus sonst ist es oft klar unter
den wolken ist die nacht am mildesten 12
bis 15 grad sonst kühlt es ab auf 7 bis
11 grad morgen ist es dann am kühlsten
an der küste mit 19 bis 22 grad frischer
böige westwind sonst mit 23 bis 26 grad
im breisgau
auch morgen eventuell schon 30 grad denn
richtung südwesten und richtung
nordwesten ist es morgen eben richtig
sonnig am ersten finden wir die wolken
vom nieder und mittelrhein bis zu oder
und neiße an der ostsee oder auch im
osten bayerns aber auch hier nur
vereinzelt regen der gesamteindruck ist
sehr freundlich am sonntag ist dann noch
mal mehr sonne drinnen vor allem in der
mitte des landes bei 19 bis 30 grad die
neue woche startet dann gleich mal so 34
grad kühler und gewitter sind wieder mit
dabei am dienstag ist es aber schon
überwiegend trocken genießen sie noch
ihren abend